Peter
Barrett excuse me my name is
Sophia and my mom called you Peter
biometric watch contains a hard drive
with sole access to his contacts stolen
Intel we want it all back she wanted you
to find someone named Peter my name's
Mark I wish I could be more help you
were CIA like my mom right you're a
really good painter oh hey kids stop
those a private this is her this is my
mom so you do know
[Music]
her go upstairs last Dar lefts the
bathroom lock the door and get in the
tub what's
happening
you are Peter Barrett how'd you find
me what do you know about Peter Barrett
the painter Bo murdered eight federal
agents in Cold Blood what I am looking
for
someone it's me Peter where are you can
I trust you two agents shut up my
doorstep today asking about
you he's hiding
something I'm the only one who can
protect you tell me about the people who
came to kill me she thinks that you're
in possession of something that poses a
major threat to our national
security I'm going to find out who took
your mother away from you and then and
then he'll do what he does mind if I
borrow a few
things
[Music]
I don't want to do this
kid